my research team found a photo of you i
don't do this kind of thing often i
don't believe in it
but we found a photo of you from college
that i found quite shocking can we put
this up please
[Applause]
now
[Music]
i had no idea you were a mustache guy i
was a mustache guy
yeah yeah so high school i was a
mustache guy really i was a mustache boy
yeah were you a mustache
baby i may well have been wow so you had
a mustache at a very young age
very young as soon as i could grow one i
probably could have grown one when i was
about 11.
i grew one specifically in high school
because i played lacrosse and i thought
it would make me look more intimidating
you know you look through lacrosse
helmet and you see this guy in
freshman in high school he has a
mustache i don't want to go up against
that guy
yeah that's the guy that you'd be but i
don't know if that guy i'm afraid of
no that's flanders you know in the
simpsons it's got a different look
that guy he doesn't he doesn't uh
intimidate people right and he doesn't
get the girls
you weren't i can't find that hard to
believe you didn't you didn't get you
didn't get the ladies
um not no not so much not so much i
thought see
i thought that that was a good look for
me i truly did right
obviously yeah yeah no i i i we all did
things
in that age that i used to have my hair
like feathered
parted in the middle and like feathered
back oh yeah like farrah fawcett
nice i thought that was my look we still
haven't found my luck
you have to look for the look yes thank
you i had
i had sort of a dutch boy my hair
was prior to this look yeah i had sort
of a long
my hair grew out this way as opposed to
long so it was just a
so you were like the killer on no
country for old men you weren't i was
javier
you were javier barton it was modeled
after me as a child